[Music]
one show the lovers and a for somebody
like me Ed Sheeran's new album divide is
definitely a departure from his previous
records about heartbreak which makes
sense because the 26 year old is in love
Edie opened up to ETS Jennifer perros
about his relationship with girlfriend
cherry Seaborn how important is that for
you to reach this level of Fame and you
know you get to go home every night to
somebody who is no new since 11 years
old I think it's cool you know you don't
you don't get away with it you don't get
away with a lot because you know she can
call you out on anything but it's you
know I've got I've got all the same
mates from school and we're all the same
friendship group and it just feels feels
a very tight-knit community I live a
very very fortunate but very surreal
life and getting caught up in that
stillness can be damaging I think so
it's good to go back and have reality on
the topic of shapes
check out Edie slimmed down fizzy and he
revealed the secret to his body
transformation I just started living a
healthier lifestyle you know I change
smokes I drunk a lot a lot of alcohol
and a very unhealthily and I just kind
of cut 70% of that out I still do all
those things we're just not in excess my
dad said anything in moderation
[Music]
you